depuis le début de confinement les êtres
humains de tous horizons se sont
soudainement rendu compte que vivre 24
heures sur 24 entre quatre murs n'aide
en rien la santé mentale
tant et si bien que nombreux sont ceux
qui essayent de sortir en douce
moyennant intéressant stratagème parfois
pas piquée des hannetons
[Musique]
alors deux choses d'une on va se calmer
un peu sur le mélodrame
parce que oui nous sommes enfermés mais
avec provision bouquin confort moderne
et même parfois internet par c'est pas
non plus le ban et de deux ça peut-être
en surprendre certains mais il existe
des aliments qui s'enferme
volontairement dans un trou pendant 2 1
deux mois par an parfois jusqu'à cas
quand j'ai dit que j'ai enregistré une
vidéo et que j'espérais donc un silence
digne d'un monastère des bénédictins en
prière ça inclut aussi des interruptions
intempestives de ta part j'imagine que
j'ai aucun moyen d'en dissuader du coup
formidable
reprenons je disais donc il existe des
animaux qui s'enferme volontairement
dans un trou pendant plus ou moins un ou
deux mois par an alors non je parle pas
des ours marmottes et autres petits
malins qui ont trouvé un bon moyen de ne
pas voir passer le temps en hiver je
parle d'animaux qui passe deux mois bien
réveillé enfermé avec leur progéniture
dans un espace tellement restreint qui
peuvent même pas étendre les bras
toujours pas d'idée de ce dont je parle
et toi effectivement on n'en est pas
loin
mais là je parle d'encore plus petit de
sa précisément
un petit cousin le calao en réalité il
n'existe pas une mais 55 espèces de
callao répartis principalement sur des
continents africain et asiatique
certains cas là haut sont énormes comme
les deux espèces de bicornes qui mesure
plus d'un mètre de haut pour 3 à 4 kg
une envergure d'environ un mètre
d'autres sont beaucoup plus petits même
si on est loin des oiseaux mouches le
plus petit atteignant tout de même les
30 cm 2 beaucoup de choses sont plus
grosses que toi il se prétend que tu
t'en rendre compte je sais tu devrais
pas est utile pour de vrai et nous
parler du cas là ou plutôt je ne sais
pas peut-être parce que tu es un peu
leurs cousins non
[Musique]
les calaos donc son début corvidés le
groupe frère des pics martin pêcheur est
relié et autres toucan notamment mais
contrairement à tout ce beau monde
décalé non pas un plumage très coloré
ils sont généralement blancs et noirs ce
qui provoque un contraste saisissant
avec leur bec pour le coup
particulièrement voyants et de ce point
de vue la femelle et le mal sont bien
souvent aussi bien pauvre le buggy cas
là où est le seul à avoir ce qu'on
appelle un casque il s'agit de cette
structure particulière qui se trouve au
dessus des becs non alors non tu seras
gentil de pain l'inclure dans le groupe
de dégénérés qui trafiquent des morceaux
d'animaux
mais il est vrai que certains bipèdes
ont moins de scrupules
chez le calao à casque euros le casque
est constituée d'ivoire où une sorte de
blog de kératine qui peut être sculpté
comme de l'ivoire d'éléphant
c'est d'ailleurs tellement à chercher
que ça devant plus cher au poids que de
l'ordre évidemment ces oiseaux sont en
danger critique d'extinction à cause de
ce commerce avec seulement une petite
centaine d'individus encore vivant à
l'état sauvage
voilà chez les autres espèces par contre
la qualité est plutôt ce projet avec les
ouvertures en son centre pour mieux
transmettre les vibrations et donc
laissons il ne s'en servent donc pas
pour se battre comme le cas la casse que
rond mais plutôt comme une caisse de
résonance pour amplifier leur appel
quant au reste du bec on ne sait pas
exactement à quel point la coloration et
la forme bien particulière de certains
sont importants pour la vie de l'oiseau
au quotidien mais il est clair que ça
doit avoir un rôle dans le choix du
partenaire j'y viens la plupart des
espèces de callao ont un mode de
nidification bien particulier il faisait
une capitaine andré l'arbre et la
femelle 6 ans fermes
elle sent mûr et sans mur elle même dans
le trou à l'aide d'une sorte de motifs
et de blaise de fientes d'un peu tout ce
qu'ils trouvent dans la qualité du nid
elle laisse quand même une ouverture par
laquelle le mal pour aller nourrir et
elle attend sur ses oeufs
ça dépend des espèces certains callao
passe deux mois enfermés jusqu'à la
sortie des petits
d'autres n'y reste que le temps que les
jeunes sont un peu plus autonome ou en
gros un mois et quittent le nid comme la
femelle la briser le mur qu'elle a
construit pour sortir les petits doivent
alors refermé la brèche derrière l e
mail oui et non lorsqu'elle sent mûr la
femelle callao au début de cette mue
annuel mais contrairement à la majorité
des espèces d'oiseaux chez qui la mue se
fait petit à petit plus par plus pour
éviter de laisser incapable de voler
complètement à la merci des prédateurs
celle de la femelle callao est un peu
plus drastiques
elle perd toutes ses plumes de vol en
même temps et tout le temps californie
elle le passe à faire repousser son
plumage donc même si dans l'absolu elle
peut ouvrir le mur qu'elle a construit
elle ne pourra pas volé pour s'échapper
et quitter le nid elle est totalement
dépendante du mal qui vient à nourrir l
est les petits
toute la famille est condamné il ya
certainement une raison à cela
même si on ignore encore acté certains
avancent que la présence de la femelle
dans le nid permet une meilleure
protection des jeunes et que la
fermeture du nid est une protection
supplémentaire contre les serpents et
les singes en particulier pour le moment
on n'en sait pas beaucoup plus
du coup la prochaine fois que quelqu'un
se plaindre à du confinement rappliquer
pire qui peut encore faire les courses
et qu'on ne l'a pas enfermer dans un
mètre carré avec des poussins criard
alors qu'il est à moitié à poil toi va
falloir qu'on pense sérieusement à
réduire son autonomie télévisuelle ça
devient inquiétant
si vous avez envie de creuser le sujet
je vous conseille le livre en bourse the
world photography gate park on soit d
kemp qui est particulièrement complet et
très bien et castrés seul problème c'est
en anglais mais c'est toujours difficile
de trouver de la littérature spécialisée
en français elle a bien
[Musique]